tu vois c'est ce que j'ai trouvé un semblable toi mon
camarade voir à l'attrition Kathy Dossey
retour Papa Joe as-tu il y a une scie je la
permission
tes amis tu me manques Barrett
Japon demain
pardon
elle joue rajababu a choisi de dire livrer
sa propre forme au chemin de palma  de
marrón Banga pensait que Joseph était bleu
un bientot au ranch une arène
confident puto j'ai coupé en muet tristement
et encore une fois c'est notre merde est pourriez-vous dire
ce que certains fans chics pas de bas câlins au
milieu pour les inconvénients
si une mémoire procédurale
et il
divulgations
à mener  qu'avez-vous fait messieurs
c'était une installation volume 32 pour le luxe
vous